peut-être que je suis un petit peu pas
dans ton oreille
mieux
[Musique]
il a la tâche
non celle d'anne
k
[Musique]
-o et le
cas
[Musique]
ouais ça vous garantit talons sans émoi
que le clip vient de sortir ou pas au
hasard comme ça dans la rue nouveau clip
en ligne dure ouais ça y est ainsi prévu
ce magnifique site accepterez
vous payez un gars qui touche 40 mille
euros il vous coûte 80 mm à la louche
sur les quarante mille euros il va payer
à l'éthique mine d'un pochoir ou bien
s'il va s'auto avec 30000 et sur les
trente mille il va payer 20 % à 20 % de
tva sur c'est tout ce qu'ils achètent de
6 donc il nous reste 24 mille donc moi
je paye 80000 lui touche 24 mines
de bois d'achat
et tout reste en l'état
mais qu'est ce qu'ils en font
duguay